how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and the finale for
wanda vision is coming
this week we only have a handful of days
left until we get that final episode
and of course we're all wondering what
exactly are we going to get in this
final episode of course there's going to
be a huge fight but what other
huge reveals are going to happen that
are going to drastically affect wanda
and lead us
into doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness one thing that i believe
is going to happen is that wanda is
going to have revealed to her that her
father
is actually not her real father and her
true father is magneto and if you're
wondering how exactly could that happen
in the finale of one division
i'll break it down on how marvel could
do this in the finale so
simplistically and so smooth yet have an
insane impact on the future of the
marvel cinematic universe the fandom and
of course
wanda so if you love one division and
marvel don't forget to subscribe so you
don't miss
out on any of the latest marvel videos
so as far as magneto and the x-men
and mutants and the x gene is concerned
marvel just kind of threw us a curveball
in one division episode viii
one that got people thinking a lot in
one division episode 8
marvel completely changed wanda's origin
for her powers in the mcu
originally in age of ultron we were made
to think that an infinity stone
the mind stone gave her powers however
as we were recently shown in the last
episode of one division
this isn't 100 true as it turns out she
was born with powers
now a lot of people automatically said
she's a witch
she's not a mutant but she's a witch she
doesn't have the x gene
but i can tell you why she is indeed a
mutant and
her father her real father most likely
had slash has the gene 2
and is the famous mutant magneto so to
start off
wanda being a witch isn't 100 wrong yes
she is a witch
partly that would explain her powers and
the infinity stone like agatha said
simply amplified her powers
but that doesn't explain a really big
missing part of this equation
this does not explain her brother pietro
pietro was not a witch
he has super speed but he definitely
doesn't know any witchcraft
and he himself did come in contact with
the infinity stone
and as we took a trip down memory lane
in the last episode of one division the
two hydra doctors explained that
every single person that came in contact
with the infinity stone
died that is until wanda at least and
considering the fact that pietro was
alive during avengers age of ultron we
can assume that he was tested after
wanda
and survived the contact with the
infinity stone as well so
how did pietro survive he most certainly
wasn't a witch and well
marvel already called him and wanda in
age of ultron
enhanced individuals but let's just call
it what it really is
he's a mutant now when avengers age of
ultron came out
marvel did not have the rights to all
the fox x-men characters
and they couldn't actually say mutant in
the mcu
however disney now does own the rights
to all those fox x-men properties and
can say mutants and x-men or whatever
they want concerning these x-men in the
marvel cinematic universe
so what really happened with pietro to
let him survive this contact with the
infinity stone well the infinity stone
most likely awoken his
x-gene and this is pretty much what
marvel told us in the past the twins
survived contact with the infinity stone
because there was something different
about their genetics
basically they have an x gene wanda had
it in her and may have unknowingly used
her powers as a child but it really
wasn't awakened in her until she came in
contact with the infinity stone
now is she also a scarlet witch who can
use chaos magic
of course she is i'm not arguing with
that however i think that's most likely
due to the evil elder god kathone
giving her part of his chaos magic as a
kid like he did in the comics
agatha talks about the myth of the
scarlet witch and the myth is that chaos
magic never existed and the evil elder
god never existed either but in fact
wanda actually got her chaos magic from
the evil elder god who used to use chaos
magic
and i believe we'll learn more about
this in doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness
so yes she is a witch with chaos magic
but she's still
a mutant but sticking to our ex gene
story here and i'm about to talk about
how magneto comes in
i don't think that wanda is done
learning about her past
agatha could only show wanda what wanda
experienced herself
so if wanda doesn't know something then
agatha wouldn't know that either
like wanda's parents i don't think
wanda's parents are
actually who she thinks they are i think
that the people that we saw in one
division episode 8 aren't really wanda's
parents however i do believe she thinks
they are
this is something that also happened in
the comics wanda and pietro found out
that their real parents weren't
exactly their real parents but their
real father was magneto and i think
there's a very specific way that she's
going to figure this out in the mcu and
i think that is
pietro not her actual brother but evan
peters's pietro
quicksilver from a different universe
now at this point they haven't really
revealed
if he is indeed quicksilver but we have
seen him use his powers
perhaps agatha gave powers to a person
that she possessed but
considering the coincidence that this is
evan peters here
it would make sense that he would have a
much bigger role than a random person
who was possessed not to mention doctor
strange in the multiverse of
madness is going to come up and is going
to take off where one division left off
we can assume that the multiverse is
involved in some way shape or form
right now in the mcu so let's go ahead
and say that this is evan peters's
quicksilver from the fox universe
him and wanda are going to have
different stories in his universe his
mother was alive
and he found out that his true father
was magneto
and at the end of one division which is
of course the next episode when evan
peters quicksilver is finally released
from agatha's spell
him and wanda are definitely going to
talk they'll talk about everything that
happened and most likely realize that he
is from a different universe and will
reveal that her father is actually
magneto
wanda would most likely want to ask this
pietro about his life in the other
universe if she is alive if their
parents are alive
because most of what is happening in one
division is about wanda's past and her
trauma
and wanda and evan peters's quicksilver
actually brought up their parents a
couple of times
in a couple of different episodes so
once everything is said and done she'll
most likely want
to ask again when he's not under
agatha's spell and perhaps this is where
quicksilver could reveal something to
wanda like
those actually aren't our real parents
our real parents actually ended up being
these people one of those of course
being magneto because even though they
do come from a different universe why
would the parents be different when
quicksilver does in fact have super
speed and his sister most likely has
powers just like wanda he could say we
thought our father was one person but he
turned out to be this incredible mutant
who fought with the x-men and professor
xavier
then wanda could say something like what
was our father's name
well we called him eric but he went by
magneto
i believe that something along the lines
of this could happen at the end of one
division maybe even in a post-credits
scene but recently in an interview
kevin feige the president of marvel
studios did kind of admit that
wandavision is a gateway for the mutants
to enter the mcu
which is another reason to believe that
she does in fact have the x gene
and perhaps they could name drop
somebody like magneto professor xavier
the x-men
after all if this quicksilver is going
to stick around in our universe perhaps
he will look for professor xavier's
mansion and the school for gifted
youngsters
either way wanda's true parents have
always been a really weird topic in the
comics
but the reoccurring story for wanda and
pietro in the comics is they thought
their parents were
certain people when they turned out to
be different people and i think that
marvel is definitely doing this in the
mcu and i think it would be
a great gateway to introduce magneto and
the mutants
but we'll have to wait and see until one
division episode 9
this friday in the meantime don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos be sure to let me know
what you think about this theory in the
comments down below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
bye